I wanted to create this quick video on a
question someone had why did Kiko spike
my heart rate so let's just go through
this normally if your pulse rate is
higher it's because you have low
potassium and that could come from
eating too much sugar or actually taking
too much salt which indirectly lowers
the potassium because potassium Calmes
the heart down or let's say you're
taking diuretics that could deplete your
potassium or you're not consuming enough
vegetables so potassium is like the most
important thing for regulation of heart
rate the other thing is if you're
deficient in potassium it can cause the
heart to work harder and it can make a
pounding sound you can even hear it in
your ear and that usually comes from
consuming a lot of carbohydrates or
sugar something like that so this could
be the reason why your heart rate is low
and then you just want to take
electrolyte powder you consume more
vegetables stop the sugar you could
consume more salt as you have more
potassium but if you have low potassium
you don't want to eat a lot of salt
because you want to look at the ratio
those ratios are actually more important
than even the total amounts and of
course the diuretics you have to get
with your doctor on that point the next
reason is you have low vitamin b1
because you're consuming too much sugar
or grains or you're on metformin which
depletes b1 by the way in which case you
need to take nutritional yeast and that
should bring the heart rate down there's
one less thing the gallbladder when you
start keto you're doing more fats if you
are not used to that many fats and you
can't tolerate that many fats that can
create pressure in the organs and
congestion and actually indirectly put
pressure on the heart which can speed up
the pulse rate these two are not the
issue then what you do is you want to
cut down on some of the fats especially
MCT oil the little keto bombs and any
extra types of fats that you're
consuming just cut that down a little
bit and that should help you one other
thing you can do is you can actually
massage the little bile ducts around
that area I put a link down below on
it's called gallbladder flushing you're
not actually fleshing out the
gallbladder but you're actually
releasing the pressure that's something
you can do as well if you feel a lot of
bloating especially after eating
alright thanks for watching so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications